absolutely delighted to introduce Luis
von Ahn who is one of our most
innovative professors of computer
science at Carnegie Mellon in the early
1990s Carnegie Mellon innovated in
computer science by creating an
institute of human-computer interaction
a discipline that uses psychology and
design to figure out how computers can
be programmed to not only be fast and
reliable but actually helpful to humans
lluís innovated even further he studied
how humans could be programmed to be
useful and help computers the invented
capture of the program that asks you to
type in the characters that appear to be
handwritten or drawn for security
purposes but behind the scenes CAPTCHA
is actually using your labor to help
computers to be better at reading hand
drawing characters he also invented a
game called ESP which is an incredibly
clever game that recruits humans to help
computers label images and to remote
players who can't communicate are
presented with an image for example of a
woman's purse or a handbag and they're
asked to label the image and if their
labels agree they get points and they
get a new image and thousands and
thousands of humans including two of my
daughter's played this game for
thousands of hours so thanks a lot for
that and if you think Google Images has
ESP you would be correct because they
bought it and have used it for many many
years after receiving a MacArthur
Foundation Genius award one of many many
awards lewis has gotten for being
stellar lewis used some of the prize
money and funding from the National
Science Foundation to do initial
research for duolingo which is a
language learning app that's now been
used by over 40 million people all
across the world and in 2013 it was
named an iPhone app of the year and
androids best of the best so duolingo
collects enormous amounts of user data
and uses these data to continually
refine its
structural approach he wasn't trained as
a learning scientist nor language
instructor nor as a specialist in
machine learning
but now Lewis has become all three so
please welcome one of the most creative
and original thinkers I think in the
world today Luis von Ahn okay can you
hear me okay yes okay good so I am from
Guatemala this is a public service
announcement that is word bottom.i is
and that is not where they keep the
prisoners that is Guantanamo okay now
when I was growing up in Guatemala I
wanted to be a businessman in I in fact
had an amazing idea what I thought I was
12 okay I thought it was an amazing idea
for a business I thought I was gonna be
a gazillionaire because of this business
so and here's the ID it turns out it's a
really bad idea but here's the idea when
I wanted to do is I wanted to have a gym
actually I wanted to have a lot of gyms
that would that where the idea was that
going to the gym was free it was a free
gym how awesome is that it's a free gym
but all the machines in the gym and all
the electrical all the bikes and
everything were hooked up to the power
grid and we would sell electricity that
was generated by the kinetic energy of
people exercising I was I will not the
first person to have this idea of course
but at the time I thought I was so this
is what I wanted to do and I thought it
was an amazing and it turns out it's a
really bad idea
for one humans are actually very bad at
generating electricity and for two
actually this is a little-known fact but
the way gyms make their money is by
having people not show up so this didn't
quite work out so I was frustrated by
that I then decided to come to the u.s.
to study
I've left Guatemala frustrated so I came
to the u.s. to study and then I I was
fortunate that I Co invented a
technology that has been used by
literally billions of people and also
hated by them which is these captures if
you have ever had to type them I'm sorry
so invented that then I became a
professor of computer science here
Carnegie Mellon then I sold to companies
to Google
and then after that I decided to work on
the project that I actually really
wanted to work on from the beginning and
it is it is a project on education it's
a it's a project called duolingo which
today has become the single most popular
app for education in both iOS and
Android platforms all over the world and
now this talk is about seven kind of
tenants or ideas that I've been thinking
about for the last four years that have
to do with education and that is kind of
a manifesto of what I think about
education and also what duolingo thinks
about education so some of these things
are just things that probably I'm not
saying that they're correct I'm just
saying you probably should just think
about them and and that that's that
that's what I'm saying okay so now my
thinking on education started from the
fact of where I'm from I'm from
Guatemala and one of the few things
about what I'm out of that you should
know at least this is a very poor
country and I always a lot of people
always talked about how education was an
equalizer it would bring equality to the
whole world but actually I always saw
education as a huge divider because what
happens is the people that have money
are able to afford the best education in
the world they can pay for themselves to
go to Harvard and then therefore they
continue having money because they will
they get a really good education the
people who don't have very much money
can barely learn how to read and write
because the educational system in
countries like Guatemala completely
sucks so they can barely learn how to
read and write and therefore continue
being poor because they kind of don't
really know how to read and write okay
so I always saw education as this big
divider and I wanted to do something to
equalize this so this is something that
I wanted to do and so I started working
on a project for education which was
duolingo now I wanted to know I knew I
wanted to work on education but I for me
education is very general so I decided
to work on just one aspect of Education
one vertical and it was one type of
education that is huge throughout the
world and it is learning languages it
turns out that today there are about 1.2
billion people around the world learning
a foreign language
now this market is actually very
interested in when when I started
looking at it it turns out about 800
million of these 1.2 billion people
satisfy three properties first one is
they're learning English second is they
the reason they're learning English is
to get a job or a better job or further
their economic life and then the third
is that they are of low socioeconomic
conditions okay so basically the
majority of these people are poor people
learning English so that they can not be
so poor that's the majority of people
learning a language but it's ironic and
it's funny that most of the ways there
are to learn a language actually cost a
lot of money for example in the US this
rosetta stone it's a program that cost
about 500 dollars in Latin America is a
competitor to rosetta stone it's called
open English is a firm the cost about
$1000 so is this the irony here is that
most of the people trying to learn a
language are doing those so that they
can get out of poverty but in order to
learn a language they kind of have to be
at a party this is this kind of negative
cycle so this brings me to the first
thing that I went when I started working
on doing lists the first thing that kind
of really it was important for me when
we started working on dual language that
the best education money can buy should
be free not luxury and I really we
really do believe that in doing well
this is what dueling was a completely
free product you can you never pay to
learn a language will do a lingo okay
now it's a good question if you're gonna
have a completely free education you got
to figure out a way to make money out of
it or somehow finance it so this is
where the idea for the gym which didn't
actually work out at the beginning
actually came back so you know the
question became how do we make a free
way to learn languages in such a way
that it is self-sustaining and we you
know I started thinking about this idea
of the gym and the question became how
do we get something out of the people
that are learning a language how do we
produce something at a value like
electricity out of the people who are
there are anyways trying to learn a
language that was the question it
depends how you can do that from people
that are learning a language and it is
through translation so here's here's how
duolingo finances itself the way it
works is that whenever you're you learn
something on duolingo at the end of
learning a lesson for example you learn
food words at the end we say hey if you
want to practice what you just learned
with real-world material here's an
article that is related to food it may
be something from a food blog or a menu
or something that needs to be translated
but somebody is willing to pay to
translate this article and you can
translate it to practice what you just
learned okay so for example CNN is one
of our clients where the idea is that
they
all of their news in English then they
send it to us then we actually send all
of the news to our students who when
they're practicing their English they're
translating all of CNN into their native
languages and then when that translation
happens we send it back to CNN and they
pay us for the translation it's very
similar to this Jim except as opposed to
electricity people are using their
mental power which is much better than
the electricity because we're very bad
at that so this is what duolingo is it's
basically a way to learn a language is
while simultaneously translating stuff
from the web let me play this one-minute
video that shows the concept a little
better so hopefully you can hear this
it's a big world out there billions of
us trying to Live Love prosper and make
sense of our brief time on this planet
since the dawn of humanity we've been
passing information from one person to
another through a common language
unfortunately you can't communicate with
others without knowing or learning their
language first a similar issue is
manifested on the web where text can be
penned in dozens of languages each of
which demands a reader's fluency we've
developed an elegant solution to both
problems a way for you to learn a
language for free while at the same time
helping to translate text from the web
enabling a wealth of language shackled
information to be liberated for all of
humanity it's called duolingo here's how
it works let's say you're a native
English speaker who wants to learn
Spanish we start by giving you a
sentence from a Spanish web site and
asking you to translate it wait back up
how can you translate a language you
don't know first duolingo only gives you
sentences that fit your language level
beginners get the really simple
sentences from the web and advanced
users get the more complex ones this way
everybody becomes a valuable translator
and second if you're really lost you can
always see possible translations for
words you don't know
afterwards duolingo helps you understand
and memorize the words you hovered over
through educational examples you can
also vote on the quality of other
students translations which helps you
learn by seeing how others translated
the same sentence and because you create
valuable translations while you learn we
return the favor by offering duolingo
completely free of charge
no ads no hidden fees no subscriptions
just free to put the potential benefit
of duolingo into perspective think about
this if 1 million people would use
duolingo to learn the entirety of
English Wikipedia could be translated to
Spanish in just 80 hours duolingo learn
a language while translating the web
ok so that's the basic idea and this
actually on this thinking this is
something else is another tenant that I
actually really do believe and we do
believe that duolingo that education
should support itself not lean on other
people's funding and the reason for that
is because other people's funding
usually comes with other people's ideas
and influence and we prefer to be just
like that and also another reason for
that is a lot of in a lot of countries
education is supported by governments
and unfortunately I would say about 90%
of the world's government pretty much
stuck so I think we can do a better job
now today do a link with the most
popular way to learn languages there are
in fact more people in the United States
learning a language on duolingo actively
than there are people learning a
language in the entire United States
public school system and just to show
efficiency we spend about 5 million
dollars a year supporting duolingo the
United States spends about 2 billion
dollars a year teaching people foreign
languages ok so this is just in terms of
efficiency now one of the reasons why
duolingo is so popular is because we
spent a lot of effort making sure that
it is really good for mobile devices and
for example this is the first time so
last year Apple chose dueling was their
iPhone app of the year and this is the
first time that Apple has ever chosen an
educational app for iPhone app or they
are usually they pick they pick games or
like picture-taking apps is the first
time they chose an education app so this
is another tenant that I that we also
believe in duolingo is that education
should be in your pocket and not just in
some building I mean it's fine that you
can go get educated in a building but if
we
really want to reach the whole world it
has to be in your pocket because that is
the only way to reach people for example
at the end of this year there will be
more cell phones more mobile phones than
there are people in the world okay and
in the next 10 years the bottom people
the bottom billion about half of them
are going to have some sort of
smartphone so if you actually want to
reach the majority of people you should
think about mobile not just web now
another reason another thing that
another reason why the link was so
popular is because we spent a lot of
effort making sure that it is really
engaging so actually playing using
duolingo feels a lot like playing a game
actually most people that when they talk
about using duolingo they say they say
playing duolingo as opposed to using
duolingo and this is this is what you're
building to actually used to look like
but basically learning a language or a
new language split up into skills into
these different units that we call
skills so for example food is a skill
animals is a skill and the way it works
is at the beginning there's only one
skill open which is basics one but when
you complete that you unlock new skills
so it really feels like a game where
you're unlocking new content for each
skill we also have this strength bar
that shows how well you know each skill
and that strength bar if you do things
correctly relating to that skill it goes
up if you do things incorrectly relating
to the skill goes down and it also
naturally be caves so if you don't do
anything relating to that skill it goes
down by itself this is to model the fact
that you're forgetting things okay so
and this by the way is one of the things
that gets people coming back a lot to
learn because they whenever the the bar
is full that skill turns gold and people
want to keep their tree gold that's what
they refer to it as doing keeping the
tree goal so people come back a lot to
do that now if that's not enough for
people to come back we actually have a
lot of tricks to get people to come back
for example we send them an email with
our mascot crying it turns out so we did
a lot of tests to try to figure out what
is the thing that gets people to come
back the most it turns out guilt works
really well and we even tested how many
how many what the size of the bottle at
the bottom we even tested that and how
many tears he should have this guy is
the winner I don't of all of that and
the actual exercise is the way they look
is whenever you're learning a language
is just little exercises that just teach
you tiny concepts
and each time and and for it for all of
our exercises you can either get him
right or wrong and whenever you get
something and the types of exercises are
you may tell you to say something and it
tells you whether you said it correctly
or not or you may have to select the
image of the boy or something and
whenever you get something wrong you
actually lose the life so the each
lesson has three lives that we show us
hearts if you ever play the game Zelda
this is where those hearts come from and
if you get something wrong you lose a
life
and if you lose all three lights you
have to start the lesson over okay so a
lot like a game but if you're able to do
the whole lesson without losing your
three lives then you get points and you
know you're told a bunch of really good
things and you get points and this is
one of the things that gets people to
really play a lot so this is another
another one of the things that we
believe into the lingo is learning
should be fun and not a drag okay and
that's one of the ways in which we get
so many users now when I started working
on duolingo it was was funny I knew
nothing about how to teach languages and
neither did my co-founder who was a PhD
student here at Carnegie Mellon severn
neither was Newton knew anything about
how to learn languages or how to teach
languages so what we did is we went to
read a lot of books about how to best
teach languages we just read a bunch of
books but very quickly we realized
something funny about this it really
reminded us of books about diets they
all contradicted each other so you know
with diets some of them say oh you
should only eat meat other ones say you
should never eat meat it really was like
that with how to best teach a language
some others said one thing somebody said
the other thing and it really were
directly contradictory with each other
so we had no idea what to do so what we
did is we kind of listened to some of
what the book said and we started with
its own curriculum our own curriculum
but then we realized we were in our
unique opportunity to do something which
was to actually figure out what really
was the best way to teach a language
because we had so much data from people
learning so this is yet another of our
tenants that education we based on data
in our opinion a lot of these books were
about philosophies of different things
and when we were in a position and we
really were in a unique position when we
had millions of uses that we could
really figure out the best way to teach
a language so what we started doing is
we started doing a lot of a B tests to
really figure things out so for example
we wanted to know whether we should
teach plurals a little earlier or
littler later we wanted to know that
none of these books could tell us
so what we did is we just did an
experiment with the next 50,000 people
that signed up but it takes about 12
hours for 50,000 people to sign up to
duolingo so for the next 50,000 people
to sign up what for half of them at
random we gave them plurals a little
earlier than for the other half and then
we measured which ones make less
mistakes which ones come back more often
which ones have better learning outcomes
etc and we just figured out that one of
those was actually better than the other
one and then we started teaching it to
everybody that way and then we do that
every single week we do multiple a B
test every single week to try to figure
out what is the best way to teach
languages okay and so this is this is
what we're doing and because of that we
just well it was about a year ago
somebody did a study of how well you can
learn with duelling when they found that
you can learn one semesters worth of a
college class of language education in
about 34 hours which is less than a
semester of college education so so
we're very proud of this but I actually
think we can do a lot better this is
comparing duolingo against the classroom
and well here the thing about classrooms
if you don't know this you should really
know this is the blooms to Sigma problem
it is it is really good and really bad
at the same time here's the here's
blooms to Sigma promises been measured
in multiple different areas of education
and the experiment is the following you
compare the learning outcome or you
compare people that are in a classroom a
standard classroom say of 30 kids or 50
kids or whatever against the performance
of people who have a one-on-one tutor it
turns out that people who have a
one-on-one tutor perform two standard
deviations that's where two sigma comes
from two standard deviations better than
the people in a classroom okay they are
so that means they're in the 98th
percentile okay so people who have a
one-on-one tutor so we know that
one-on-one tutors are actually better
than classrooms but there's a reason why
we don't do one-on-one tutors it's just
not scalable to have a one-on-one tutor
we would have to have as many teachers
as we have students and that kind of
doesn't work out so but I think this is
one place where technology can really
help because your one-on-one tutor could
really be a computer and this is I mean
there's a whole area of learning science
that is really trying to figure out I
figure this out and this is something
that we're not quite doing with duolingo
but it's something that I want to do and
that it's that I really do think that
big data in general should be used
personalized education not just a
personalized ads for example me we're
spending I don't know how many billions
of dollars and trying to figure out what
is the best ad that we can give some
person that's great people can make
money off of that but I think we should
use exactly that same technology to try
to figure out what is the best next
exercise to give people now the so this
is one of the things we're working on a
duolingo the other thing that we're
working on kind of for the future and
this I um this is the thing that I'm
very excited about because it's also
something thats related to Carnegie
Mellon because Carnegie Mellon is a
partner on this and it is so this this
started as following as follows a lot of
we teach languages a lot of the emails
we get say things like thank you for
teaching us a language this thank you
for teaching me a language for free
because I couldn't afford it before now
you can now I can learn a language
that's that's really great but I have a
problem I need to get a job or I need to
get accepted into a school and I need to
have a certificate that shows that I
know English could you give me a
certificate and we get a we would use to
get a lot of these emails of people
asking for certificates and then we
started kind of looking into what is
this whole certification business that
there's actually a whole certification
business certifying that people know a
language particular this only matters
for English so it's really certifying
that you know English is a huge business
it turns out to be about a twenty
billion dollar a year business
certifying that you know English and the
way it works is that there are these
tests
there's standardized tests that you have
to take and when you take it at the end
you get a score that's you know that's
certified that's as yeah this is how
well this person knows English for
example to get admitted here to a
university in the United States if
you're a foreign student you have to
take a test called the TOEFL that test
you know proves that you know enough
English to come to the universe to come
to the University now there's the thing
about all of these tests all of them are
kind of regional monopolies and because
of that they're very expensive they're
about so all of the tests for some
reason I don't know they're doing price
fixing or what but for some reason
they'll cost about the same amount they
cost about $250 each okay now it's that
sounds like okay it kind of sounds like
a lot of money but if you're from a from
a developing country two hundred and
fifty dollars it's about a month's
salary which is insane that that's what
you have to spend to certify that and
for example I was just talking to
president Suresh who said that he
actually had to take the twelve
and he back then in India the test cost
fifteen dollars that was that was it
right fifteen uh but he actually
couldn't afford the fifteen dollars
because it was just so expensive so this
is this is a huge problem that
international students have to have have
to pass through all the time but it's
not just the cost it's also the case
that the way you take these tests is you
have to go to it's like taking the SAT
you have to go to a testing facility to
take the thing to take the test and and
so you got to go to a testing center now
the problem is these testing centers
first of all you have to make an
appointment weeks in advance which is a
problem and second they're not in every
city so if you don't live in one of
those city you have to travel and this
is a huge problem so what we did is we
decided to make our own tests to certify
that people know English the way it
works this it uses you you take the test
from an app as opposed to having to go
to a certification center and it costs
20 dollars not two hundred and fifty
dollars there's a reason why cost only
dollars we actually wanted to make it
free but there's a reason why it cost
twenty dollars and the reason is because
you see the reason you have to go to a
testing center when you're taking one of
these tests is to make sure that you're
not cheating that's where you have to go
to a testing center to make sure that
you are you and you didn't send a friend
of yours and also that there's nobody
helping you now if you're taking a test
from an app this is a problem you may be
able to cheat but what we do actually is
that we turn on you have to take it with
a smartphone you turn on the front
facing camera and then we actually
record you taking your face and
everything while you're taking the test
and also the microphone so we'll record
the whole thing and then we send that
recording to a proctor somewhere else
that watches you take the entire test to
make sure that you're not cheating and
to make sure that you are you and of
course we have to pay the proctor to do
that so that's why it costs money so
that so that's the basic idea let me
play you this um it's about a minute
video that also explains the whole idea
of the test center every year over 30
million job seekers and students around
the world are forced to take a test to
prove that they know English or other
languages in order to apply for a job
school
these tests can require paying an entire
month's salary traveling to a distant
examination facility and then waiting
weeks in limbo for the results we think
there should be a better way a fair way
where those trying to get ahead aren't
exploited duolingo the free language
learning platform has created a test
center app to give everyone equal access
to jobs and educational opportunities
now anyone can conveniently certify
their language skills from home on their
mobile device and for only 20 dollars
that's one-tenth the cost of existing
tests it's scientifically proven
remotely monitored by real people and
supported by progressive institutions
around the world duolingo join the
movement so that's the basic idea of
this we launched this about a month ago
and we've about 20,000 people have taken
the test now and more and more people
are taking it to certify their tests one
of the things that one of the hardest
things about this will be really busting
the monopoly so trying to get people I
mean trying to get people to accept our
test as opposed to say except the the
TOEFL et cetera and this is one of the
things that we're working with with
Carnegie Mellon here trying to really do
it and what we have to do with the
burden of proof is on us we have to show
that our test is as good as the TOEFL at
Accenture for foreign student applicants
and so what we're gonna do is in
conjunction with CMU we're gonna do a
relatively large scale study that shows
that our test is as good as the TOEFL so
that's that's that's what we're working
on and this brings me to the last tenant
and this is something that I think this
is one of the things that I think is
probably the most controversial and most
people probably won't agree with this
but I really do believe it and we do
this I do it with everything we do at
duolingo we really do try to do this and
it is we design for the student and not
for the system and this is important so
if you look at most educational
technology startups over the last few
years they have decided that they're
actually going to spend all of their
time designing designing for the system
so they're designing for schools they're
designing for whoever because that's
where the money is you design for where
the money is so they're trying to make
you know for example something that will
teach better Spanish to the way schools
teach Spanish
we don't do that at Wingo at all we
always design for the end user not the
middleman so this is exactly what we're
doing with a test center for example we
looked at what was bad for the student
point of view not from the institution's
point of view and then we try to fix
that problem same with duolingo we look
we don't care about how the you know
Canadian school system teaches French or
we don't care about how different school
systems teach anything because we don't
want to be bound to how it is however it
is they teach their own thing we decided
that we want to teach the way we want to
because we think we can actually do a
better job because of the big data that
we have and then maybe people will adopt
our system so we we do that I don't know
if I don't know if anybody else agrees
with this but we do this we don't design
for the system and so that is that is
actually all that I wanted to say thank
you
could you could you please Dan Adkins
University of Michigan can you say more
about the the peer evaluation of the
quality of the translation and the
process by which these multi
translations converge to something that
you for example send to CNN yeah the way
that works is so a single student
usually is pretty crappy at doing the
translation so if we just send it to a
single person they're not very good at
it but what we do is we send it to
multiple people and they actually can
see each other's translations and it's a
bit like a wiki where they can edit each
other's translations but it has one
extra item which is that you can also
vote on somebody else's translation so
if you see somebody else's translation
and you think this is really good you
could you up you vote it and when when
that the way it works is that whenever a
given translation has been there for a
while and has enough up votes then we
say okay that translation is good and
then that's kind of how it converges and
I sentence one sentence one sentence so
that's the quantum ah yes but the thing
is you can see actually the whole
document at once so you only vote on
each sentence we can see the whole
document once so people are pretty good
at saying well given the previous things
I think we can change that and at the
end of the day the results are so that's
all we do and at the end of the day the
results is such that we send it to it's
good enough I mean CNN has been our
client for maybe about a year and three
months or so and we haven't been fired
so so it's good enough for that yes hi
Albert hi Louis nice to see you again
great presentation thank you so there
was in the first panel I'm not sure if
you were here or not there was a
discussion of whether universities could
be leaders or laggards and adoption and
promotion of educational technology you
might be a case study here at least in
weather education so are any educational
institutions picking this up and using
it and how is it going even though you
designed as you say for the student not
the system even case studies even
without names might be very valuable to
it yes so um so definitely education
institutions are using are using this um
I don't have all the data because we
don't we asked
little from the users we don't know our
estimate is there maybe 250,000 students
in throughout the world using duolingo
in schools that's our estimate well we
know of the the government of Colombia
is about to start doing it in a lot of
their public schools and the government
of Guatemala is already doing it in some
of their public schools and so that's
for the learning part and we definitely
get a lot of emails from teachers
etcetera so it's definitely there that's
from the learning part for the testing
part which is something else that we
really want to get adopted um we're
talking to about 12 universities that
are none of them have universities
rightly so are skeptical of whether this
is as good as the TOEFL but they are you
know over the next year or two the idea
is that through you know to do tests
with the admission cycles so that they
start accepting this or the TOEFL and
and as soon as they start accepting this
or the TOEFL and pretty confident that
ours will win because it's a tenth of
the price and you can take it and get
results in 24 hours as opposed to wait
for eight weeks so yeah I'll try this
again how do you deal with I'm TJ bliss
from the Hewlett Foundation how do you
deal with copyright issues since you're
pulling content from the web you're
trying yeah we're translating yeah most
of the free content on the web is not
actually licensed so that you can
translate it legally
so have you how do you manage that yeah
this is a funny thing copyright
copyright kind of sucks for us but what
we do we actually what we do is we only
translate things that are either
Creative Commons in which case we
translate it for free and then we just
rented it or you have to upload your
copyrighted content and we charge you so
for example you know BuzzFeed is another
one of our clients our students actually
happen to love BuzzFeed it's funny but
they they uploaded themselves so if it's
copyrighted you have to upload it
yourself and we're gonna charge you and
that's the idea we're not going on and
crawling the web for it because we would
get into a lot of trouble although we
would like to may of you may have
simplified for the discussion but it
sounds like when you tried to design
were to test out the learning
progression so where you made a decision
to change the place where you teach
plurals yeah that you've made a decision
that a singular learning progression
should be applied to all the students as
opposed to potentially bearing it yep
can you talk about that decision because
I'm sure you didn't come to it lightly
yes so this is where we are in the
development of duolingo right now every
student gets the same progression I
don't like that we know that's not the
best not just progression there's all
kinds of things that we need to
personalize we're not personalizing it
yet we're working this is the main thing
we're developing our personalization
right now what we think we have is we
have a single curriculum that we think
is good for the aggregate that's much
better than I think for example the
single curriculum that is used in most
say educational systems throughout the
world with that which is also a single
system that's what we have what we think
we know in fact we can do better for
certain you know by doing different
things so what really what we want to do
so the next version of duolingo it's not
really the immediate next version of the
world and go probably about six to nine
months from now the way it's going to
work is that when you start it's going
to first ask you a couple questions so
it's gonna say what do you want to do so
it's not just about learning English why
do you want to learn English do you want
to because you want to get a job is it
because you want to take a trip is it so
what do you want to do that's the first
thing then the second thing we're gonna
say how much time you got
alright good then the next thing we're
gonna do a tiny you know maybe a five
minute test to try to figure out roughly
how much English you know or how much
the language it is that you know and
then we're gonna we're going to spend
some computing power and then we're
gonna design a curriculum basically that
it's just for you based on that so that
that's kind of that's where we're going
and that's where we want to be we're not
that yet Luis Anouk from Microsoft
again as an amazing presentation and as
a domain you know me the results you're
showing it just amazing my question was
more about this problem in itself is
really really important to solve but as
you go to other domains you know you
would you say you know learn calculus
this way or physics this way what do you
think where would you say this approach
is appropriate and where would you say
you know something totally different is
needed as we look at the problem
yeah that's a really good question and
something that we grapple with all the
time because what I actually wanted to
do when I started was I wanted to do
education not just language education
but we started by just with one vertical
and and I think it was the right call I
mean if you look at it for an app for
example now we have more active users
than Coursera Udacity and EDX combined
so I think and they teach everything
whereas we only teach one thing so I
think it was the right call
to really do just concentrate on one and
really try to get it right and we're
nowhere near getting it right I think
we're I don't know 5% of getting it
right but we're gonna start going into
other and to other verticals I think one
that we really like a lot there's a few
there's a couple that we like a lot one
is teaching coding we're not the only
ones there's a lot of people trying to
teach coding and another one is basic
literacy these are two that we like a
lot I don't know which one we're
actually gonna go for but we are gonna
do order for the verticals so I think
this approach applies for a lot of
things I don't know if it'll apply for
everything but I think most of these
tenants they're general enough that I
think they definitely I mean it should
be mobile for example this is one of
those things they whatever you do it
should be mobile so all of these things
I think it applies but I think there may
be we may have to do a lot of changes
for that I mean right now we're
extremely fine-tuning language and I
think when we start with anything else
we're gonna be because of all the
technologies that we've built we may be
I don't know
20% of the way there for something else
but we'll have to the other 80% because
there's a lot of fine-tuning for that
okay thank you